أنت تعرف اليوم أنني كنت شخصًا يمكن أن تفتخر به دولة إسبانيا بأكملها وشخص سيفخر به ابني في المستقبل ، لذلك هذا بالضبط ما أشعر به ، نعم أنا متأكد من أنك تعرفه قبل أسبوعين فقط اضطررت إلى الانسحاب من البطولة التذكارية التي كنت تقودها بست ضربات لأنك كانت إيجابية بالنسبة للسرية 19. أتساءل كيف قادتك هذه التجربة إلى ما أنت عليه اليوم بعد 15 يومًا فقط ، فأنا أعتقد أنه من أكبر الانتكاسات. أعتقد أنه في بعض الأحيان من أكبر الانتكاسات ، يمكنك الحصول على بعض أكبر الاختراقات وأعتقد أن الكثير من الناس اعتقدوا أو اعتقدوا أنني كنت غاضبًا من الموقف أكثر مما كنت عليه حقًا ، ولم ألوم أي شخص أبدًا لم أكن مستاءًا أبدًا من أي شيء هذه أشياء أنا لا يمكنني التحكم فيه ونحن في منتصف جائحة ، كما تعلم ، كان لدي الكثير من الأحباء ، الكثير من الأصدقاء الذين تعرفهم يعانون بل وحتى يموتون من هذا ، لذا كان أول ما فكرت به هو أنني أتمنى ألا يحدث ذلك سيئة
مثل الصحة لا تتدهور وأتمنى ألا يكون لدى
أي شخص آخر في عائلتي ، خاصةً
ابني البالغ من العمر شهرين ،
هذا ما كان عليه رأيي عندما أظهر
الجميع نتائج إيجابية
ii آسف سلبية بقيت إيجابيًا
عقليًا وأنا أعلم أن
بعض الأشياء والأشياء الجيدة  كان من المقرر أن أتيت
وأنت تعلم أنني مؤمن كبير بالكارما ، لقد
بقيت إيجابيًا وكل هذا أتى ثماره
اليوم
كما قلت ، كما قلت ، أعتقد أن الأشياء الجيدة في الكرمة
تحدث لأناس
طيبين وأنت تعلم تحولت
إلى أفضل سيناريو ممكن اليوم
لذا فإن سان دييغو وتوري باينز هو
مكان خاص جدًا لك ولعائلتك
لمن مشاهدينا
الذين ليسوا على دراية بقصتك ، لماذا
يعني هذا المكان الكثير بالنسبة
لك إنها قصة طويلة بعض الشيء ولكنها
كذلك  كانت المدينة المفضلة لزوجتي قبل أن
نلتقي بها وكان والديها يأتون إلى
هنا ويقضون عطلة
طوال الوقت ، كانت مدينتي المفضلة
أيضًا قبل أن نلتقي ، ثم بدأنا دائمًا في
المواعدة وقضينا بعض اللحظات الجيدة التي
جئناها
بالفعل إلى هنا في الكلية عندما
كنا  "  أعود إلى المواعدة لمدة شهرين ولم
تحمل لي
أي فكرة عن عربة الجولف بالنسبة لي يوم
الاثنين مؤهل من
تأمين المزارعين المفتوح لقد
فاتني بعد عام من ذلك ، فزت بأول
حدث لي معها هنا
بعد فترة وجيزة من خطوبتنا هنا  في
مسارات توري باين
وأنت تعلم بعد ذلك بوقت قصير
أنني حصلت على أول فوز كبير لي ، كما تعلمون ،
إنه بالتأكيد مكاننا المفضل على هذا
الكوكب في كل مرة نأتي فيها
نشعر بالراحة ، فنحن سعداء بشكل طبيعي
بغض النظر
عن حقيقة أنهم  كنت قادرًا على التواجد هنا من
أجل هذا أيضًا في وقت لاحق من العام
وإنجازه ،
هذا ما يجعله أكثر
خصوصية لهذا السبب قلت إن
هناك شيئًا مميزًا في الهواء
اليوم وأعتقد أنه يبدو
وكأنه حكاية خرافية  أه
انظر ، تهانينا على أول فوز كبير لك ، من
الواضح أنه
تهانينا للاحتفال بعيد والدك الأول
أيضًا ،
كيف تعتقد أنك ستصف هذا
اليوم في المستقبل
لابنك كيبر أنه سيكون قادرًا على
رؤية الصور
ورؤيته  إذا كنت شابًا صغيرًا ، فسيكون من
المستحيل أن أشرح بصدق ،
لكنني سأبذل قصارى جهدي لأكون هنا
معه ، سيكون أول فوز لي
بصفتي أبيًا حاضرًا ووجودي
هناك في 18
كيلي يسير معه في  الأسلحة التي
تعرفها
في تلك اللحظة كل ما كان يدور من
حولي
يختفي تمامًا ، أنت تعلم أنه يمثل
الأولوية له ولها
وما قمت به وما أفعله في
المستقبل لن يهم مطلقًا
مقارنة بما يهمني وكيف
أنا أحبه كثيرًا بالنسبة لهم ،
وهذا ما سأستمر في إخباره به
بغض النظر عما أنجزه في الحياة
وبغض النظر عما حدث حولنا
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم
، كان لا يزال أهم شيء
سيظل عليه إلى الأبد
وأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف ما إذا كنا سنتمكن من
فهم حجم هذه اللحظة
لنفسي ولنا ، لكنني سأحاول
التأكد من أنه يفهم